the opening scene features a guy who
finds himself confined with an a large
Cube comprised of various compartments
in his quest to escape he Ventures
through different compartments at one
point he enters a room that sprays him
with an unfamiliar liquid initially he
freaks out thinking that it's acid but
as he tastes it he finds out it's sweet
the man assumes that it is flavored
water and desperately drinks it to
quench his thirst however to his dismay
the liquid turns out to be a powerful
chemical base that gradually melts his
entire body within a few minutes
ultimately resulting in his death it is
then revealed that all the rooms in the
cube are under constant surveillance
from a remote observation room where two
technicians named Eric and Dodd work
they are oblivious to the identity of
their bosses and are strictly prohibited
from accessing the files which are not
related to their tasks despite this
restriction Eric is increasingly curious
about the events occurring within the
cube and attempts to inquire about them
to DOD however the latter dismisses him
rudely based on their knowledge Eric and
daughter are aware that everyone within
the cube has either been condemned to
death or is willingly choosing to
participate in psychological experiments
during their work the two technicians
engage in regular chess matches where
Eric demonstrates his remarkable mental
calculation abilities by predicting
God's moves alongside their duties they
are provided with some tablets as their
Meals one day Eric and daughter tasked
with a significant assignment to record
and erase the memories of a subject
named Cassandra Reigns in her memory
Eric Witnesses Cassandra and her
daughter strolling happily through a
forest however their piece is abruptly
shattered when they are abducted by a
masked soldier who injects them with
sedatives before passing out Cassandra
manages to unveil the soldier's face
revealing a distinct Cube tattoo on his
forehead later she regains Consciousness
and finds herself trapped within the
confines of the cube she's in that guy's
forehead somewhere she calls for help
but is expected no one can hear her out
realizing that her fate is in her own
hands Cassandra finally starts exploring
her surroundings she somehow manages to
reach the adjacent room but as soon as
she enters another captive named Robert
Haskell throws her to the ground he
tightly restrains her until he realizes
that she is one of them in the room
Cassandra meets three other occupants
Jellico meyerhold and Bartok they appear
to have been trapped here for weeks
surprisingly Robert Bears the same Cube
tattoo as the soldier who captured
Cassandra and Bartok shares a name with
a cartoon Bat from Anastasia however
none of the group members possess
memories of their past lives or any
recollection of how they ended up here
motivated by a shared desire to escape
they collectively decide to head in the
same direction hoping to locate an edge
as a result the captives navigate the
intricate chambers of the cube
cautiously testing each room for
potential traps at first bartakis is a
method of throwing his shoe and waiting
for signs of danger when he doesn't see
anything wrong he assumes the room is
safe and proceeds inside unfortunately
his assumption proves fatal as he soon
becomes trapped in a network of threads
that slowly get tighter cutting his body
into
the cartoon bat fared a little better
following the terrifying incident the
remaining victims continue their search
for an Escape Route after a bit of
discussion they learned that each door
within the cube Bears English alphabets
Cassandra deduces that these alphabets
actually represent coordinates providing
information about the position of each
room within the cube they speculate that
the cube is comprised of a total of 26
rooms correlating with the number of
letters in the English alphabet acting
upon this realization the group begins
investigating other rooms discovering
that the rooms along the z-axis are
deemed safe meanwhile in the control
room Eric becomes curious and decides to
uncover why the people are imprisoned
within the cube he then devises a
proposition offering to teach Dodd
various chess strategies in exchange for
information concerning the cube Dodd who
is intrigued by the offer shares details
about the Cube's third auxiliary unit
but refrains from divulging any further
specifics in the next scene Eric's
curiosity intensifies when he notices
the Cassandra's consent form is missing
he quickly informs Dodd saying that
whatever they are doing is illegal but
Dodd once again dismisses him their
attention is then caught by Cassandra's
photograph in a newspaper revealing her
to be a politician this Revelation leads
Eric to realize that the cube not only
targets criminals but also innocent
individuals without their consent
shortly after Eric and Dodd receive a
call from their superiors issuing a
directive to carry out an exit procedure
it is revealed that the procedure
involves their former colleague Owen Who
currently serves as a test subject
within the cube for this purpose Dodd
prepares a machine equipped with a
camera and a yes no button a Zone
approaches one of the Cube's exits he
becomes trapped by thick chains in this
critical moment Dodd poses several
questions to Owen inquiring about his
name and his belief in God despite
hearing God's voice Owen fails to
recognize him indicating that his memory
has also been erased he answers
correctly to the first question
prompting Dodd to press the yes button
however when confronted with the second
question Owen denies his bill belief in
God leading him to press the no Button
as soon as he does so a fire engulfs him
killing him instantly witnessing all
this Eric begins to panic realizing that
they too could meet a similar fate at
any given moment he reaches the
disturbing conclusion that the Cube's
existence is inhumane and people are
being forcibly placed inside against
their will a few hours later Eric
becomes so paranoid that he decides to
venture into the cube himself he now
wants to save the remaining victims from
their impending doom for this he enters
the unauthorized elevator which takes
him all the way down to the cube then
using his extensive knowledge of the
place Eric draws a map and memorizes it
well before embarking on his mission to
join Cassandra and the rest of the group
meanwhile a superior named Jax
accompanied by his associates arrives at
the control room they are aware of
Eric's entry into the cube so they
utilize controlling machines to track
his whereabouts amidst all this Jax
orders Dodd to initiate a standard
series of needle tests on Cassandra and
the rest of the group elsewhere inside
the cube Jellico takes the initiative to
investigate a room she doesn't want to
do it but she has no other choice
unfortunately the decision turns out to
be a bad one as soon as she enters the
door behind her abruptly shots Cassandra
Hurley opens the door but to her shock
Jellico has already vanished this
unsettling incident reveals that the
rooms inside the cube are in constant
motion meanwhile Angelico explores her
room Dodd locates her and administers a
sedative injection to her feet rendering
her unconscious after searching for
several hours Cassandra and the group
finally find Angelico lying motionless
meyerhold carefully approaches her and
turns her over only to discover that her
body has been afflicted by some sort of
infection just then Jellico wakes up and
clutches onto meyerhold pleading for
help however in a defensive act
meyerhold pushes her away accidentally
causing her to strike her head against
the wall this results in her death but
meyerhold soon realizes that his hands
had been scratched while she was
clutching onto him fortunately before he
can react the infection starts spreading
across his body as well recognizing the
potential danger he poses Robert
suggests that they leave meyerhold
behind he claims that the guy is only
going to slow them down or Worse infect
them as well however despite all of this
Cassandra asserts that they cannot
abandon the poor man when meyerhold also
starts pleading Robert agrees but on the
condition that he inspects all
subsequent rooms before the group enters
with no other viable option meyerhold
reluctantly agrees and the group
continues their journey in the next
scene meyerhold proceeds to check a room
located beneath them but Robert suddenly
pushes him downward the room turns out
to be a trapped one that emits an
incredible high frequency sound this
sadly kills meyerhold in seconds as
expected Cassandra expresses her
disappointment and engages in a heated
argument with Robert she calls him a
betrayer who only cares about himself
just as things are about to turn violent
Eric enters the room and asserts that
what Robert did was right because the
virus was highly infectious plus it
wasn't even that loud they just played
some Imagine Dragons and he keeled over
Eric then introduces himself as an
employee and proceeds to divulge secret
information about the cubes he explains
that the occupants volunteered for this
experience despite having no
recollection of it however Robert
angrily claims that he never signed any
consent form and committed no crime he
mentions that he used to be a
hard-working delivery boy before he was
abducted but in reality Robert has no
recollection of his past life meanwhile
Cassandra inquires about her daughter
prompting Robert to share some sketches
he made he claims that he saw the girl
in her memories overwhelmed Cassandra
loses control and attacks him but Robert
stops her reminding her that they need
the man Eric also assures them that he
is here to help as he can analyze the
coordinates and guide them towards the
third auxiliary exit on the other hand
Jax's Associates locate Eric's
whereabouts and display the information
on their monitor in response Jax orders
them to erase all coordinates of the
room and surround the occupants with
traps and after successfully confining
them within one room Jax activates the
electrification of the walls to
potentially kill them however a sudden
power outage disrupts their connection
with the cube turns out Dodd had a
sudden change of heart and he was the
one who sabotaged the operation this
action deactivates all the traps within
the room and initiates a reset mode the
prisoners are now granted a 10-minute
window to escape before a sterilization
procedure begins and vaporizes
everything inside Eric quickly realizes
the dot has assisted them so he sets a
10 minute countdown timer on his watch
and leads the group to the exit in the
control room Jax eventually learns of
God's treachery ends while he kills him
as punishment after this he accesses an
implanted ship within Robert's brain
granting him control over his body Jax
then manipulates the programming and
orders Robert to eliminate the others
before they can successfully exit the
cube following the order Robert becomes
hostile towards his former Companions
and launches a brutal attack on them
however Eric and Cassandra team up and
somehow managed to subdue him the two
then head forward and eventually arrive
at an exit room only to discover Robert
waiting for them he once again attacks
the duo and almost manages to choke Eric
to death but fortunately Cassandra comes
to the rescue and impales him with a
sharp metal object finally killing him
you just got cubed she says the two then
hastily enter the auxiliary accent just
before the sterilization procedure
commences following this Eric and
Cassandra swim through water and emerge
in a lake they make their escape through
a forest that eerily resembles the one
depicted in Cassandra's memory earlier
unfortunately Jack's soldiers also
arrive at the forest and start chasing
them during the pursuit Eric is sadly
tranquilized and captured but before
losing Consciousness he manages to hold
the soldiers back momentarily allowing
Cassandra to escape later on Eric
regains Consciousness and finds himself
in a surgical room where Jax reveals
that Eric has been convicted of high
treason and that he had agreed to
participate as a test subject Jax also
presents a consent form with their
Eric's signature although the latter has
no recollection of it following this
Revelation a surgeon proceeds to alter
Eric's brain during this he dreams if
Cassandra reuniting with her daughter
and praising him as a superhero a
superhero with the same IQ as the Green
Lantern in the final scene Eric who is
now mentally disabled is held back
inside the cube where he is found by the
new captives he repeatedly mentions the
color of the room and expresses his
desire to return to a room with a
different color
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on the notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching